let me bring back dan hicks uh so the
catty dan
he's relatively new there at band and
dunes
yeah he's uh apparently he is a first
year caddy abandoned dunes
and apparently in this covid protocol
situations they have here you have to
take a couple of tests uh covet tests
before you get inside the bubble and
you're
then able to caddy for you know one of
the participants in this u.s amateur
so a lot of the uh longer term caddies
here abandoned dunes chose to stay out
of the bubble and caddy continue
chatting at the other courses that are
that are that are here at band of dunes
so
this guy you know wanted to you know be
a part of the us
amateur and and ended up uh you know
connecting with the
segundo oliva pinto of argentina and
that's how he ended up you know on the
bag and what the crazy thing is
is that pinto posted last night on his
instagram story
hey he's a good friend it could happen
to anyone
and hashtag no one's fault
so it's amazing how pinto has continued
to have this caddy's back
even though and i i think it's fine i
think pinto took the high road here you
don't want to
you know throw anybody under the bus but
at the same time
you know my my issue is that the guy
just flat out you know didn't tell the
truth
and i i think that was i think that was
clear from the video and everybody that
was there
on the ground including tyler strafaci's
dad frank who we've got a little bit
in the situation there saying he clearly
you know saw him do it and all that so
so i that's indefensible not telling the
truth but it is interesting how pinto
decided to
uh take the high road i mean this this
could have changed pinto's life he's
from argentina obviously plays his
college golf in the united states but
you know now now he's he has no shot to
be the u.s amateur champion which is the
the biggest you know
most prestigious amateur championship in
the world so i had never seen anything
like that happen especially
when a caddy makes the mistake
it was uh it was just a first timer for
all of us so dad got involved
afterwards this is i talk about tyler
his opponent tyler
bocce's dad yeah uh during if you if you
watched the telecast last night
he comes in and when they're when when
pinto
and uh the caddy brant brewers his name
are talking to the
officials there tyler's dad who's
catting for tyler the kid who's
competing against him
said hey you know i saw what you did you
clearly touched the sand
and he got in there in defense of his
kid
as to what the opponent was doing so you
know it had a little bit of everything
you never know you know these these us
amateurs are a little bit like the
olympics you just you know you're gonna
have drama before you get into them
but you never know exactly what kind of
drama so
it was uh it was unprecedented as far as
what we've seen happen
but about etiquette and golfers are
really good you know
most 99.9 are really good at policing
themselves
uh but in this situation what is the
etiquette when the caddy of the opposing
player
is the one who's ratting you out on tv
well uh you know in this case it was uh
we saw the video it wasn't like the
caddy of the opposing player i mean he
he he wanted
he wanted to get his you know he wanted
to fill in more
information to the officials
that really didn't need his uh his take
yeah i think
uh dad's uh frank sirpachi and you know
they come from a long
lineage of golfers who dating back to
his grandfather who you know won all
these championships back in the 30s and
anyway so yeah so this this what what
was interesting if you saw the video
pinto is clearly didn't see it i do
believe that he did not see
his caddy brant brewer in this case tess
the sand
because there's this shot that we had of
him just kind of looking over what kind
of shot he was going to play on the edge
of the bunker
but he wasn't looking at the time that
brewer had his hands
on on the sand and was scraping around
so you know it was it was terribly
unfortunate i feel so bad for pinto but
i i just think the dynamic of him
of him taking the high road is is pretty
amazing when
this caddy cost him a chance at this uh
this championship but also the overhead
shot dan
was just awesome to have that video
where oh
yep yep that was the real clincher to
have that
unquestionable video i mean you know i
immediately started thinking
it's crazy this game and all these shows
we do i immediately started thinking of
patrick reed in the bahamas
you know last year with with his sand
controversy brushing the sand back
which he was penalized for uh but you
know
denied that he was he could feel pushing
the sand back or saw him pushing his
hand
outside his club pushing the sand back
so in this case
it was just it was so clear
that it was surprising to to hear the
caddy
say he didn't do it so it was pretty
clear-cut we had uh colin morakow on
after he won the pga championship
and you talk about star power i mean his
personality his smile like ability
and and he's not a bomber you know he
said i'm probably in the middle of the
pack here but
he's only 23. i know we keep waiting for
that next golfer
whether it was spieth or justin thomas
or rory or whoever it's going to be but
what do you make of what you've seen
from colin moricawa
yeah you're right we we we always tend
to say well you know this guy's got it
all you know when spieth was doing it
and he
did have it all for a time he borrowed
it for a while so to speak which is the
popular saying in golf but
by all accounts and i've had a chance to
for a couple of quick visits with colin
murakawi he is
so impressive and we have uh
steve burkowski that is with us at this
u.s amateur who
lives and breathes college amateur golf
and who's known colin maracala for a
long long time and he told me yesterday
we were talking about this very thing
he said kalamarakawa is singly
undisputed most impressive
young player that he's ever come across
as far as having the entire package
the the wherewithal the demeanor
the skill set the entire package to be
what we think is going to be maybe one
of the more impressive careers maybe
he'll end up
being even more impressive than than
spieth in the end or justin thomas i
mean those guys are
you know already have a head start on
him but he i i think i don't think it's
hyped to say that connor morikawa is
going to have a star-studded career
now are you rooting for just a normal
broadcast
uh you know the next round here or do
you want
do you want what do you want what are
you rooting for
hey i'm all for the drama you know i i
you know we we're getting down we have
uh we have eight guys left
and we are we are commercial free
if you haven't noticed and so we've got
plenty of time for drama
we you know so let's let's bring it out
let's let's see something today that
we've never seen like you saw last night
right
i'm all for it i'm all for it and you
know after a while
you kind of run out of bio notes you
know what i'm saying yeah yeah
i i i it's fun it's a lot of fun these
kids are great
this has always been one of my favorite
tournaments to do because
you you know it is so intimate there's
no ropes and
not that you have to worry about that
now with no spectators but it always has
been a favorite of mine we get to the
weekend
these guys are playing for a chance to
get an invite to the masters in the us
open
the open championship so it gets really
good especially on the weekend
have fun dan thanks we'll be watching
all right i'll keep the sand out of my
eyes here in ben and i'll do my best
all right that's dan hicks nbc sports
abandoned dunes that's the 120th u.s
amateur live coverage continues tonight
airing exclusively on peacock from 6 to
7 eastern
continuing on golf channel from 7 to
nine also
coverage over the weekend on saturday
and sunday